[Musica]
diversi anni fa ho fatto un sogno
piuttosto particolare sognavo di essere
insieme a mio padre e ci guardavamo con
versavamo finché a un certo punto
l'atmosfera intorno a noi si è riempita
del profumo buonissimo del fiore
d'arancio il nero ii e in questo sogno
io contemplavo questo profumo e il
profumi entrava dentro e in qualche modo
mi dava un senso di piacere e di gioia
quindi quando mi sono svegliato ho
immaginato ritrovare nella stanza lo
stesso odore come se qualcuno avesse
spruzzato la fragranza è che questa si
fosse insinuata nel mio sogno invece
nella stanza non c'era alcun odore
particolare e quindi ho realizzato di
aver fatto il mio primo sogno olfattivo
vorrei quindi e chiedervi approfittare
di questo pubblico per sapere se è
capitato anche ad alcuni di voi di fare
dei sogni adori cioè di sognare non solo
immagini e suoni ma anche profumi odori
alzate la mano per favore fantastico
bene quindi da oggi non siamo più soli
effettivamente la facoltà di immaginare
gli odori
esiste anche se molti molte ricerche
alcuni scienziati specialmente in
passato negavano questa possibilità
della nostra immaginazione quindi in
qualche modo immaginare un odore era
ritenuto inimmaginabile e quindi questo
precludeva la strada della conoscenza è
come se gli odori fossero troppo
vincolati al qui ed ora e ci impedissero
di dare accesso ad una conoscenza di
tipo astratto concettuale
quindi abbiamo per esempio dei libri
come quello di engel che diceva
impossibile richiamare un odore alla
mente in assenza della fonte di questo
odore e così via
facendo questo sogno il fattivo mi sono
interrogata su questo tema cioè che
cos'è che fa di noi dei segnatori
olfattivi e cos'è invece che ci rende
sognatori anno smici come la maggior
parte forse delle persone
e questo tema e molto poco studiato se
non in ambito forse patologico per cui
qualcuno ricorderà i libri di oliver
sacks sulle fantasmi e quindi condizioni
appunto di malessere apparizioni di
odori che non esistono nella realtà
in condizioni normali cioè uno studio
recente su un piccolo campione di
persone che ha un po dimostrato quello
che il nostro senso comune ci dice cioè
che i sognatori olfattivi sono quelli
che nella vita di tutti i giorni
prestano maggiore attenzione agli odori
quindi le persone per cui l'olfatto è
una sfera sensoriale piuttosto
predominante nella vita gli stessi
creatori di fragranze che molto
raramente e prendono la parola si
esprime non raccontano il loro mestiere
raccontano proprio queste esperienze per
esempio edmond de rubeis che sosteneva
di non comporre con le essenze che aveva
davanti quindi con l'organo del
profumiere sentendo le varie
combinazioni ma di costruire le sue
formule completamente a mente
quindi esattamente come un compositore
di musica immagina la musica una melodia
una partitura sentendola nella sua testa
senza bisogno di suonare le note sul
pianoforte
quindi la facoltà di richiamo
effettivamente è possibile è molto poco
esercitata molto poco studiata la sera
olfattiva ricopre un po un ruolo
marginale nella nostra nella nostra
cultura viene ritenuto un mezzo
diciamo noi fallibile di conoscenza e
quindi non ci porta diciamo conoscere la
realtà
questo per altri pregiudizi per esempio
il fatto
le percezioni olfattive sarebbero troppo
soggettive quindi vincolate al nostro
umore al nostro stato di salute
agli ormoni per esempio che cambiano
completamente il nostro modo di sentire
gli odori quindi la soggettività arriva
è un pochino impedisce una conoscenza
universale un altro pregiudizio per
concetto sul sugli odori sulla
conoscenza olfattiva e che noi abbiamo
trilioni di odori pensate che sono stati
calcolati che il nostro è stato
calcolato che il nostro naso riesce a
sentire fino un trilione di odori
eppure non abbiamo costruito dei codici
e fattivi cioè non abbiamo imparato a
raggruppare questo tour in categorie
condivisibili per cui abbiamo ad esempio
le sette note musicali
abbiamo i tre colori primari ma non
abbiamo una sorta di scala appunto degli
odori
ma al di là di queste argomentazioni che
varrebbe la pena così di sviscerare e di
così affrontare in modo più specifico
ciò che pesa un po sull'olfatto nella
nostra cultura è un pregiudizio
culturale ci portiamo un poco dietro
l'idea che il senso dell'olfatto
appartenga alla sfera animale e che
quindi annusare abbia sempre qualcosa di
un pò sconveniente che non si addice
alla buona educazione
appartiene un po la sfera animale questo
ha un piccolo fondamento nel fatto che
il fatto è l'unica sfera sensoriale è
l'unico senso gli odori vengono
decodificati direttamente nell'area
limbica del nostro cervello quindi la
codifica avviene istantaneamente in
questa zona ancestrale del nostro
cervello che è l'area limbica la prima
che si è formata e quindi questo fatto
in questa zona noi elaboriamo tra
l'altro emozioni e ricordi
questo fa sì che l'olfatto venga
percepito come un senso preistorico un
senso un po fossile ma realtà degli
recenti studi di paleoantropologia hanno
mostrato che proprio l'accrescimento dei
nostri bulbi olfattivi e stato
determinante nella formazione delle
nostre capacità cognitive e quindi nella
nostra abilità comparto comportamentale
e sociale e quindi l'olfatto ha davvero
accompagnato l'uomo nella sua evoluzione
tutt'altro che un senso fossile un altro
pregiudizio di tipo morale e quello che
vuole un pò l'olfatto questa escrescenza
al centro nel del nostro volto come
qualche cosa che appartiene sempre alla
sfera traumi sospeso tra umano e non
umano pensiamo che ciò che il naso
caratterizza per esempio personaggi come
quelli delle fiabe le streghe i troll
delle mitologia nordica
oppure le maschere della commedia
dell'arte tant'è che uno studioso ha
scritto le maschere si dividono in due
categorie quelle con il naso
d'arlecchino è quello con il naso da
pulcinella e vediamo qui una pulcinella
nell'opera di uno scultore lello
esposito esposto
a spaccanapoli e questo naso adunco
caratteristico prominente
addirittura pare consumato perché i
turisti sono soliti andare a strofinarlo
a toccarlo per allontanare la malasorte
quindi qualche cosa che fa paura crea
sgomento con un naso fuori misura
diventa per una curiosa inversione un
mezzo per allontanare la paura assume
c'è una funzione apotropaica e vediamo
qui un altro personaggio della del
carnevale e quindi del mondo
all'incontrario nasuto pantalone il loro
parente più giovane la marionetta
pinocchio e visto che siamo a bologna
citerei anche a ricordare il naso a
becco d'uccello di zanardi è uscito
dalla fantasia di andrea pazienza le cui
gesta infrangono il senso comune e
mettono in discussione il politically
correct e sicuramente dove c'è un naso
c'è sempre una beffa
c'è un raggiro un'impostura pensiamo al
gesto del marameo che è una forma di
canzonatura forse in origine era una
forma di saluto e sicuramente di questo
atteggiamento del naso il fatto che il
naso un po ci prenda per il naso
ne sa qualcosa il protagonista di un
famoso racconto di gogol il naso appunto
da cui sono tratte queste illustrazioni
il naso arriva questa appendice del
nostro corpo questa antenna protesa
verso l'ignoto che esprime tra l'altro
un senso di curiosità di andare a
cercare qualche cosa oltre di noi
non a caso è una persona particolarmente
curiosa ed invadente viene chiamata
ficcanaso in questo racconto il naso
dichiara l'autonomia del corpo del
protagonista inizia a vivere una vita
propria ed ecco qui un altra scelta ha
una critico letterario come mikhail bach
team non era sfuggita questo elemento
del naso nella letteratura popolare
aveva detto il naso alla caratteristica
universale di mettere in discussione i
confini tra il dentro e il fuori
ed è proprio così infatti se ci pensiamo
bene quando noi guardiamo un immane
e questa ci rimane in qualche modo
esteriore abbiamo l'illusione che qua ci
sia il soggetto elice sia l'oggetto e
che quindi sia possibile una conoscenza
oggettiva nella realtà con gli odori
invece questo non accade dobbiamo
inalare l'odore dobbiamo farlo entrare
questo rappresenta potenzialmente un
pericolo per il nostro corpo e questo
mandava anche un po in sconcerto i
filosofi del passato che ritenevano
appunto che l'olfatto non era
attendibile perché troppo soggettivo non
andava ha detto quella possibilità di
conoscere di conoscenza oggettiva del
mondo
in effetti questa caratteristica del
naso ha creato anche un progressivo
allontanamento degli odori da parte
della nostra civiltà secondo un processo
che vale ancor ben ha raccontato molto
bene nel suo libro la storia sociale
degli odori a partire dalla fine del 500
la fisiologia e la medicina iniziano ad
attribuire agli odori proprio la cagione
delle malattie non conoscendo ancora i
virus ei batteri si era immaginato che i
cattivi odori potessero veramente
minacciare la nostra salute
ed ecco quindi creare una barriera nelle
nostre vite nel nostro corpo per evitare
di essere penetrati dagli odori
sicuramente erano molto penetranti
dell'epoca e inizia una battaglia contro
l'odore contro il cattivo odore tant'è
che gli faceva una ricerca per esempio
nel database dei marchi e dei brevetti
tempo fa mettendo la parola autore
escono una miriade di invenzioni contro
il cattivo odore quindi per molto tempo
noi ci siamo interessati agli odori
sopra mente soprattutto per abbatterli
per cancellarli dalle nostre vite è una
sorta di fobia
olfattiva che ha fatto sì che lo stesso
core ben ci mettesse in guardia c'era la
nostra società sta per diventare a noi
mica tra poco non saremo più in grado di
sentire gli odori
in realtà fortunatamente forse stiamo
assistendo a un'inversione di marcia
negli ultimi anni ci sono stati dei
grandissimi progressi nella conoscenza
dell'olfatto
pensate che la sfera olfattiva e ancora
pochi poco conosciuta nel suo
funzionamento tutto quello che sappiamo
è stato scoperto negli ultimi 50 anni
quindi a partire dall inizio del xxi
secolo si sta facendo strada una sorta
di rivoluzione culturale olfattiva
l'olfatto torna ad essere al centro
dell'interesse da parte degli scienziati
degli studiosi della medicina pensate
anche alla tecnologia alla messa a punto
dei nasi elettronici ma anche sul piano
artistico estetico c'è sempre più
interesse verso un riconoscimento per
esempio della profumeria come forma
d'arte come approdo estetico della sfera
sensoriale olfattiva e sicuramente in
questo modo andiamo recuperare qualcosa
che in passato forse noi sapevamo è che
un po abbiamo smarrito cioè che dietro
l'olfatto la percezione degli odori c'è
una vera e propria forma di intelligenza
sappiamo che oggi va di moda catalogare
le intelligenze addirittura adesso nere
sono state identificate sette tipologie
d'intelligenza non soltanto quella
logica matematica ma quella musicale
quella interpersonale eccetera
sicuramente una di queste l'intelligenza
olfattiva qualcosa che gli antichi
chiamavano sagacia i latini chiamavano
la sagacia ed era una forma di
perspicacia una capacità simile a quella
degli arioli e cioè della
di chi faceva appunto delle premonizioni
di anticipare ciò che sarebbe accaduto
nel futuro quindi l'intelligenza
olfattivo intelligenza estremamente
intuitiva e predittiva e vorrei quindi
concludere un po il mio intervento
mostrandovi un paio di applicazioni
della sfera olfattiva che potrebbero
veramente cambiare col tempo il nostro
paradigma conoscitivo che attualmente è
basato sul dominio sulla predominanza
della vista e dell'udito
noi conosciamo soprattutto ciò che
appunto vediamo ma l'immaginazione non è
soltanto immaginazione visiva vorrei
comunicarvi questo immaginazione può
essere immaginazione anche olfattiva
quindi una di queste applicazioni è
sicuramente l'introduzione precoce e
dell'educazione olfattiva nella vita dei
nostri bambini
quindi fin da piccoli iniziare a
costellare la vita dei bambini di odori
attraverso ambienti olfattivamente
stimolanti
oggi siamo abituati a fotografare gli
istanti della nostra vita tutto viene
veicolato attraverso le immagini e la
nostra memoria dei momenti più belli
prima qua dietro dietro questo
palcoscenico ci si fotografava cercavamo
di ricordare appunto di portare memoria
di questo momento e quindi questo ci
rende un po dipendenti dalle nostre
memorie esterne di device di memoria di
silicio che sono estensioni esterne
della nostra mente la memoria olfattiva
invece una memoria organica sicuramente
interiore e molto particolare abbiamo
detto già prima del legame molto stretto
tra odori e memoria per il fatto appunto
che gli odori vengono decodificati
nell'area limbica del nostro cervello
deputate all'elaborazione delle memorie
a lungo termine quando noi ricordiamolo
dure non lo ricordiamo ma in quanto tale
noi assimiliamo il contesto in cui
l'abbiamo sentito e quindi per esempio
se ci capita di sentire l'odore della
legna bruciata improvvisamente
questo questo dove in se significa poco
e diventa significativo perché porta con
sé il ricordo del tepore domestico del
legno carne nel cammino di inverno degli
affetti familiari
allora un odore ci parla e tutte le
volte che noi sentiamo l'odore
richiamiamo alla mente il contesto in
cui l'abbiamo sentito per questo che le
memorie olfattive sono molto vivide e
anche particolarmente tenaci pare
infatti che siano particolarmente
persistenti nella nostra mente quindi
l'invito è proprio di creare fin da
piccoli associazioni tra odori momenti
della vita per arricchire le vite delle
nuove generazioni di questo
potenziamento della mente noi oggi
pensiamo che la tecnologia di a tutte le
risposte legate al progresso ma il
progresso e anche tornare e anche
scoprire facoltà nuove della della
nostra mente un altro utilizzo molto
importante della sfera olfattiva voglio
parlare cioè non parliamo appunto di
approdi estetici di chi vuole diventare
il profumiere enologo eccetera vorrei
proprio parlando di qualcosa che può
coinvolgere la vita di tutti al di là
delle specializzazioni e dell utilizzo
dell'olfatto per promuovere la gioia di
vivere
già da tempo la medicina messo in
relazione il decadimento dell'olfatto
con gli stati di depressione
quindi le persone depresse sentono molto
meno gli odori e questo è comprensibile
si chiudono al mondo mentre invece
assimilare gli odori significa respirare
aprirsi far entrare cose nuove
infatti gli odori e tra l'altro non
possono essere digitalizzati al momento
la complessità degli stimoli olfattivi
rende impossibile passare trasmetterci
odore attraverso i telefonini quindi
davvero per sentire per parlare per
raccogliere la ricchezza al fattiva
dobbiamo uscire aprire le finestre
brescia il mondo uscire di casa
questo significa che l'olfatto può
diventare davvero molto importante una
delle applicazioni importanti tra
l'altro di frontiera per la medicina è
quella legata al recupero delle persone
malate di alzheimer
il recupero insomma cercare di dar loro
delle condizioni di vita migliori
attraverso l'esercizio della sfera
olfattiva e quindi il ritorno a queste
memorie che sono appunto sono entrate a
far parte di loro infatti è come se
nella limbo un po delle menti questo
labirinto delle menti che vanno la
deriva esistesse un filo d'arianna che
questo filo d'arianna fosse un filo
profumato ricordo luca che purtroppo
oggi non c'è più che aveva un negozio
che vendeva anche profumi qui a bologna
e che ci raccontava di essere riuscito
ad emergere dal coma
grazie all'odore di una succulenta
bistecca 12 piacevole che per lui l'ha
riportato alla vita e quindi
effettivamente questo ci mi ricorda
sempre l'importanza degli odori per
ritornare non soltanto come strumento di
esplorazione come abbiamo visto ma anche
come strumento per ritornare a noi
stessi anche siamo
pare che proprio gli uccelli si
orientino nelle loro migrazioni
attraverso l'olfatto e quindi vi vorrei
invitare a vostra volta non tanto a
navigare in chissà quali terre sperdute
ma a diventare osmo nauti cioè
navigatori di odori
partendo da esercizi anche molto
semplici nella vita quotidiana
rispondendo per esempio a questa domanda
con cui vi lascio questa sera quelli
sono gli odori della vostra vita
[Applauso]
[Musica]